well Backstreet Boys member Nick Carter
is being accused of raping a teenager in
2001 after our concert in Washington
state now that's according to a lawsuit
filed right here in Clark County on
Thursday 39-year-old Shannon Shea Ruth
who was 17 in 2001 says Carter invited
her to his tour bus after the show now
she says that's when she was sexually
assaulted the lawsuit also claims Carter
gave her HPV
Carter tried to scare me into Silence by
saying no one would believe me if I told
what happened
he was nasty and threatening saying I
would go to jail if I told I know now
that I wasn't the only women woman that
Nick Carter did this to
I hope that by coming forward today many
other women will find the courage to
also come forward and hold Nick Carter
accountable
well the lawsuit alleges Carter has
multiple victims now in a statement
Carter's attorney Michael Holtz said
quote the claim about an incident that
supposedly took place more than 20 years
ago is not only illegally Miss uh Merit
list but also entirely untrue